[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un nouveau livre sur le ski vient de
paraître
ski moderne aux éditions arthaud les
auteurs de ces livres jean vuarnet
championne olympique de descente à squaw
valley et georges joubert professeur
d'éducation physique entraîneur du
grenoble université que jean vuarnet
vous le connaissez comme skieur vous
connaissez toutes les victoires qu'il a
remporté un peu partout sur tous les
champs de neige d'europe et même des
états unis
mais c'est également un théoricien du
ski en compagnie de georges joubert ils
ont en effet mis au point une méthode
qui est la méthode moderne une méthode
qu'ils ont pratiqué eux-mêmes et qu'ils
ont essayé de codifier après beaucoup
d'années de préparation est également
l'observation
ils ont déjà fait paraître deux livres
le premier ski techniques modernes
le deuxième ce qui a baissé j'aimerais
jean vuarnet que vous m'expliquiez tout
d'abord qu'est ce que ce livre ski
moderne apporte de plus sur les deux
précédents vous avez fait paraître bien
nous avons nous avions décidé déjà en 56
lorsque nous avons écrit le premier
livre de rester fidèles à nos principes
c'est à dire de continuer à évoluer ne
voulions pas d'une méthode absolument
stagnante ni d'un dogme qui ne change
jamais et c'est ainsi que nous allons
été amené à faire ce qui a baissé et
maintenant à faire ce qui me donne mais
de plus ils nous avons essayé de rendre
toute chose de plus en plus facile soit
la lecture soit par la présentation et
ski moderne je pense répond un peu à
cette idée ce qui est très difficile et
ce qu'il y a justement dans ce livre
c'est que vous avez et codifier les
mouvements expliquer les mouvements en
très peu de mots ça n'a pas dû être
facile ça oui ce soit difficile surtout
quand on adore la technique en a
tendance à se perdre dans de multiples
de taille cette technique vous l'avez
mise au point après avoir beaucoup
observé lui bien sûr combien d'années
mais a émis pour écrire ses livres je
suis arrivé en 52 1 grenoble
de cet instant j'étais en contact avec
georges joubert et nous avons réussi à
faire paraître un livre à 56 56 il fait
déjà quatre ans de quelques recherches
et depuis une heure toutes choses sont
plus faciles depuis étant donné que nous
débarquions plus un novice en somme
ski moderne et quand même une
simplification de tout ce que nous
avions écrit dans ce qu'ils 1957 mais en
tenant compte quand même de l'évolution
du ski actuelle évolution qui se fait
très rapidement
vous qui avez suivi tous les coureurs
dans les champs de neige de compétition
ou savait que sans arrêt il ya des
petits détails qui réapparaissent c'est
ainsi que à l'heure actuelle on peut
considérer qu'un garçon comme guy
périllat qui a eu un accident vous avez
récemment avec une voiture a vraiment
apporter quelque chose de nouveau ce qui
qui va falloir à nouveau étudiée il
apporte un détail c'est peu de chose
mais si on se laissait dépasser par les
événements si on attendait 3 4 ou 5 ans
pour remarquer tous ces détails ça finit
par faire quelque chose par créer un
faux c'est en somme avec quelques
connaissances actuelles et les
connaissances dans cinq ans un détail
d'ailleurs que je ne comprends pas tout
de suite que l'on remarque mais sans
pouvoir l'expliquer réellement et que
peu à peu grâce au cinéma d'ailleurs
grâce au ralenti on arrive à mettre au
point
je veux dire que dans ce livre ski
moderne il y en a à peu près pour tous
il y à des exercices pour débutants il y
à tous les mouvements du ski qui sont
décrits et il ya également un chapitre
ski de compétition qui est extrêmement
intéressant et en perdant de ski de
compétition je crois que l'on peut dire
que jean vuarnet est certainement à
l'origine de cette méthode qui a permis
à l'équipe de france l'année dernière
plus tôt cette année c'est à dire la
saison dernière de ce lycéen de se
distinguer asko vague
je voudrais vous montrer comment et
présenter ce livre ses livres est
remarquablement présenter car on trouve
des mouvements exactement décrit sur
deux pages avec des petits dessins avec
des photographies voyez ici un châssis
pivoter et vous voyez ensuite tout
heureux
en théorie un chassé pivoter en
traversée fait stop voyez comme c'est
très simple comme cela est bien présenté
à propos de ses stops c'est un mot que
vous avez inventé vous même qu'est ce
que c'est exactement comme chez stop
mais elle fait stop a deux origines en
somme fait stop arrête toi est également
festons opposition ils vont découvrir
les sites en question c'est une
succession de petits dérapages dans une
traverse
autrement dit les freinages des
freinages en traversée est alors
opposition c'est une opposition de la
ligne des épaules à celle de ski la
position un peu tordu comme on l'a dit
et nous sommes à quelques semaines
maintenant des vacances d'hiver des
compétitions de ski et je crois qu'en
france les citadins aiment beaucoup se
rendre dans les champs de neige sur les
champs de neige
eh bien j'ai envie année vous êtes
partisan vous d'un entraînement
préparatoire de façon a pleinement
profité de lait des champs de neige
lorsqu'on y arrive
pour le premier jour oui en effet parce
que les gens qui se déplacent aux sports
d'hiver à noël par exemple dispose de
fort peu de temps et je pense que si on
peut leur faire gagner sur place là où
ils habitent déjà deux ou trois jours
départ c'est vraiment un bénéfice
extraordinaire combien de gens sont
obligés de rentrer en ville à leur
travail au moment où il se sentait en
forme et ça c'est très désagréable
il suffit pour cela qu'il s'entraîne
chez eux qu'il fasait la culture
physique mais aussi ils peuvent
s'entraîner à skis et cela jean vuarnet
va vous le démontrer tout de suite avec
un appareil qui l'a mis au point
d'ailleurs il n'existe qu'un seul
exemplaire qui s'appelle le home ce qui
en effet est bien l'homme ce qui les
composent et
deux skis qui peuvent pivoter autour
d'un axe de façon à représenter les
prises de cartes et il peut également
pivoter autour d'un axe qui se trouve au
sommet de l'appareil sur une plaque
bombay de façon à pouvoir refaire les
mouvements d'allègement du ski le score
de cette façon cultive en somme qu'on
appelle dans la technique logiciel la
flexion extension bien l'appareil comme
je vous ai dit tout à leur permet de
faire des reprises de car vous voyez que
il existe une bascule qui permet de
prendre une attitude de vissage
accusations l'appareil permet également
de cultiver les flexions extensions car
pour passer au centre il est obligatoire
de faire ce mouvement et on peut
réaliser aussi bien à christiania léger
que 1 christiane et moderne ou de l'agly
sur l'appareil
évidemment ça n'est pas aussi jolie que
sur la neige mais c'est cannes possible
par exemple un christiania léger et pour
questionner un média avec utilisation de
vissage accusations et en accélérant
rétine ou te de l'image du rugby
vous avez vu une jean vuarnet en salle
de la théorie à la pratique il n'ya
qu'un pas aussi et tout de suite nous
allons le voir sur les champs de neige
ce qui vaut beaucoup mieux
à force de volonté parce qu'il savait
qu'il avait raison jean vuarnet a réussi
à triompher de ceux qui ne voulaient pas
évolué et aujourd'hui certains éléments
de sa technique moderne sont adaptés
dans l'enseignement officiel du ski
français
je vous laisse admirer jean vuarnet
nouveau directeur de la station de
morzine dévalant duo du plein et ces
images ont été prises par claude fayard
juchés sur le toit du téléphérique est
noyé ici parfaitement cette méthode
cette méthode moderne
[Musique]
à
et
[Applaudissements]